what looks like an alien spaceship is
actually a tiny object made up of an air
pocket surrounding a metal ball plunging
through liquid the air pocket creates a
nearly frictionless surface and is
falling at a constant velocity
normally a solid moving in liquid is
slowed down by friction and drag so how
did researchers reduce drag to nearly
zero by creating a non wetting surface
using one of two approaches heating up a
metal ball so hot that what's called a
Leyden frost effect occurs where a vapor
layer forms between the ball and the
liquid like water beating on a hot stove
or coating the metal ball with a
hydrophobic or a super water repellent
substance the balls are then placed at
specific heights above a deep tank here
a 20 millimeter steel ball preheated to
400 degrees Celsius is dropped at a
height of 55 centimeters into 95 degree
water at impact and air pocket forms it
stabilizes into a streamlined shape by
shedding small air bubbles at the tail
until it achieves a constant velocity
the dropped hydrophobic ball also forms
an air pocket and at similar velocities
without the need of preheating the ball
or fluid previous drag reduction schemes
have also used air pockets but a very
thin layer around the object so they
basically retained their original shape
in contrast the present method to rely
on creating a very large tear shaped air
pocket from 5 to 15 times the volume of
the balls themselves changing the solid
sphere into a giant air torpedo to
determine if drag has been reduced
researchers then race the air pocket
balls against plastic projectiles with
matching weights and shapes analyzing
the high-speed footage they found drag
was reduced by 90% compared to the
plastic dummies predicting the movement
of bodies and fluids is usually
difficult because of resisting forces
but since these new methods virtually
eliminate friction and turbulence
velocities can be accurately calculated
based on the density of the ball and the
volume of air pockets next researchers
want to nail down exactly how the shapes
of the air pockets are determined since
these objects
requires so little energy to travel
through water perhaps these methods
could be applied to energy-efficient
high-speed transportation in the future
engineers are already releasing bubbles
under ships to reduce fuel costs maybe
shaping those bubbles or using them with
hydrophobic coating could speed things
along
[Music]